what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
time Tuesday everyone get your asses
back to work
Memorial Day weekend is over wall wall
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
just trying to get our lunch money right
I'm here with the beautiful intelligent
plain Tamara Nova in her midtown uniform
she's got the vest on looking like a
sheep is it mine is it real wool did you
kill the animals or did you not it's
fake you know I got this I got this in
Vegas in Vegas think I did really I
think so okay that's cool it was really
cold okay
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block Phi get money get
paid they've got three products you can
go and put in crypto I'll give you US
dollar loan you can buy and sell crypto
or my favorite product I'm an investor
and a user is that they will pay you up
to eight point six percent APY interest
in an interest-bearing account that is
way more money that you will earn on
your savings or checking account there's
risk go to your research block Viacom in
the description well they pay me to get
your vest nope no vest coming from me I
got the uniform on I wear it every day
no problem German bailouts what's going
on so Germany is now the single largest
the German government is now the single
largest shareholder in Europe second
largest airline Lufthansa nationalize
them all baby the governments around the
world only got one strategy print money
and bail them out France did it Italy
did it and then I love the CEO of whiz
Airlines or was air he said he said all
these airlines have been poorly managed
and poorly run and now they can turn to
their governments to get bailed out and
it certainly distorting the market well
first of all it's hysterical that the
German government got better deals from
their Airlines when they bailed them out
than the US government gotten the
us-based airlines the US government got
fleeced by American Airlines United
Delta
all of them right is that a joke that
wasn't a joke that was a good that's a
good pun is what they're called in the
American language and so for the German
government at least they got equity so
like okay if you're gonna bail them out
at least take equity right you're giving
them something get something in return
but no it's nationalized yeah oh by the
way countries around the world they love
this right the whole idea of like yours
becoming more depending on the
government here's the best part is that
you have the government which is a
notorious horrible cap of allocator
these governments suck at investing
capital and getting returns across
sectors they're gonna say that the
airline executives ran it so poorly that
the government's taking over yeah but I
feel like yeah and I feel like the
German government actually is doing got
a great deal so a 20 percent he took a
20% stake in luanda and the option to
boost that by an additional 5% how much
money did they have to pay nine billion
so here's the deal this is further proof
that the US government is not only a bad
capital allocator but it got fleeced in
the bailouts and the airlines made off
like bandits because if you remember the
US airlines got tens of billions and
others like a 50 billion dollars I
remember correctly 2/3 of the money that
was given to the airlines was a grant
they don't have to pay it back they
didn't give up equity for it literally
was just a grant okay okay
but that's on purpose because we don't
want our airlines to be nationalized
right exactly so tell the government
stay out of it
wipe the equity share holders out make
them lose money because that's what
happened they took risk they bought
equity in a business the business is
poorly run wipe them out
punish them it's like like having a kid
and you tell them here's the rules you
can't eat the candy you only get candy
one day a week you can't eat candy on
the other days or it's gonna be
unhealthy the kid that needs candy every
day but you never punish them instead
you just say oh you know what it's fine
here's more candy you're incentivizing
them to keep doing the bad behavior
because you're taking away the risk
instead you should spank your kid put
them in timeout and say don't eat candy
and guess what they'll stop eating candy
it's not that hard he is not endorsing
spanking on this show okay don't even
get me started the fact that people
think you shouldn't thank you
I grew up in a family of five boys if
they didn't spank us as kids my parents
would've lost control the inmates
already ran the asylum it would have
been even worse all right let's go do
yours don't bail out companies that's
the message stop bailing out these
companies the New York Stock Exchange
still stupid because now the
government's left holding the bag
literally the gut what is the government
going to do what is the German
government gonna do as the 20%
shareholder of this airline they're
gonna screw it up no they're not no
they're not good stock exchange is
reopening as lockdowns loose and further
but the people the traders will be
wearing facemasks
there will be plexiglass between his
trading station they came back to work
today and here's what I don't understand
why is the stock market up on this news
I bet bot Oh boggles baffle apples no
boggles the mind boggles the mind well
first of all there isn't the stock
market's going up is because businesses
are reopening all these different phases
in the US and they're seeing economic
activities kind of a bounce off the
bottom and so that there's hope there
the sentiment is positive and therefore
investors are speculating that stocks
will rise they start buying when they
start buying stock prices go that's
funny
what you know they always tell you to be
a good investor you have to keep your
emotions out of it yes why is the stock
market so freaking emotional because
they're not good at it like most people
probably lose money if they trade a lot
right but going back to New York Stock
Exchange
so just so everyone's clear this is just
a play it's all facade the people who
are on the floor don't do anything it is
literally just a play it's like the WWE
or WF right it's like going to see
Hamlet or Hamilton isn't that a play
Hamilton that's fine
Hamilton what's the difference between
watching Hamilton and watching these
people no difference really so okay so
they proved that they can do their work
remotely during this period
why do you need a floor I'm actually a
fan of the New York Stock Exchange right
huge fan I believe that what they're
doing is it's a it's an institution it's
got a we've gotta instill the confidence
we have to come back but the fact that
they're bringing people back on
floor with facemask and all this
plexiglass all is nonsense they're also
not allowed to use public transit
together okay you're telling me that
there's not a single person that's going
to work on the New York Stock Exchange
for us not using public transportation
they went and then they saw the news
that they weren't supposed to how are
they gonna stop them I don't know are we
gonna get fired if I if I take the
subway and I go work there do I get
fired I do not know the whole thing is
like look great I'm glad they're
reopening we all that the facade was
revealed right the there is no need for
the stock exchange floor today
everything happens in servers in New
Jersey which again is fine but it's just
a little ridiculous that like this was
this big moment to kind of instill
coffins back in the market to open up
the stock exchange floor if you remember
they actually were very slow to close
the stock exchange floor as well when
there was the health crisis whatever at
the end of the day this doesn't really
matter I just think it's ridiculous that
you know we got to get the live shots on
television and stuff with all the people
walking back in I know I wish people
like applauded knew and I came back to
work order from the couch you're fine
what's going on Amazon podcast through
its Alexa fund that's it's venture arm
is looking to make investments in
podcasts companies isn't that funny the
news comes after Joe Rogan just got a
hundred million dollar deal with Spotify
were they already making the investments
and do they say what type of investments
like well it's looking to invest in
localized podcast content like news and
sports so aka they just want to bring
radio to Alexa I think they're gonna use
Alexa I think there's some kind of play
with Alexa here yeah I mean look if you
think about so two ways that this could
go just I'll stop my head one is if you
could basically just wake up and say
Alexa tell me what's going on with the
New York Yankees
it doesn't surety do that well what
you'll do is you'll tell you facts but I
my guess is that they don't actually do
that much in terms of well localized
content all the talk radio like all that
kind of content yeah and then to is some
guy this is really weird but some guy
who thank you for doing this this was
cool
he built an Alexa app where you could
basically tell Alexa to play
Podcast and then it would play the
podcast but he had to like build
something to connect it so what it
sounds like is Amazon is basically
saying hey we can build the
infrastructure right to connect that
stuff but we need the content and my
guess is that they still can't they
can't just take the radio because
there's all these licensing deals
monetization exclusivity whatever so
they need new types of content so it's
kind of like the athletic but for audio
that's cool
according to do you want to get an Alexa
no we don't have one ask her why because
he's rude to her and I will not have
that in my house no tell him really why
wait why she says no cuz always listen
oh yeah she doesn't like that they're
always listening
I guess my phone's probably always
listening but like at least you know
what they would hear if you listened to
our conversations you would literally
hear me like walking to the bathroom
being like remember when I smoked you in
chest last night in him applauding me
when I go to work every morning okay but
but Axios is reporting that there's been
a debate internally over whether the
podcast content would live within
amazon's audiobook company audible and
was on music Amazon Alexa are all three
this is what happens we have multiple
properties that could kind of fight for
this yeah I mean if you think about
again Amazon having so take Apple Apple
has Apple music Apple podcasts right and
then it has iTunes which technically
they're all related yet they're separate
in some form or fashion same thing here
so like Apple figured that out I'm sure
Amazon will figure it out
the key is just there's two core
components to audio right now one is the
audio surfaces right or the plans so if
you think about this across podcasts
we're seeing tons of activity something
like a clubhouse which is a social
consumer application of audio or all
sorts of passive things like audio books
and that type of stuff
right but then there's the content
production and what actually occurred is
there was tons of content produced then
the platforms caught up now we're seeing
a reinvestment in content and it'll kind
of be this like going back and forth
between the two yeah because they just
need more content right there's just
actually not that much content so you
know what's interesting to me is that
podcasts have gone through so many waves
of popularity I remember listening to
podcasts when I was in high school but I
would listen to them
on iTunes on my computer podcast yeah
when were you in high school
2008 7 2007 she doesn't he yeah I have a
child on the on the show have a child
with me ok so I would I would listen to
them on iTunes on my computer but like
random like news shows are you sure
wasn't just radio know there were
podcasts like there were episodes but
what's interesting is then that there
was that wave of cereal and people were
like oh my God look how cool
storytelling in the form of like audio
episodes and now I mean it's just so
popular and just as everybody thought
the bubble had burst but we've talked
about this and you think it's because
partly because the air pods right so air
pods is definitely a huge piece of it
this is not an original idea to me I've
got people who are way smarter who tell
me all the secrets to the life but ear
pods basically made it super easy to do
passive listening so you can listen
while you're at work you can listen
while you're commuting you can do all
these different things you do the same
with headphones before you you could but
just the fact that like there's no cord
if you use air pods like I challenge you
go actually plug in your cord headphones
now I did it the other day excited to do
a cost I'm not scared that the air puffs
would die and you're like man I'm like
tethered to my phone this is weird you
feel like shackled to the phone and so
now I was something that you have to air
pods you can like leave your phone on
the other side of the room you can do
all this stuff that's first the second
piece of it that I think is really
interesting is once you go audio you
don't go back
like I don't read books anymore I just
listen to audiobooks I literally I try
to sit down the other day and read a
book I felt like I was in prehistoric
dinosaur that's okay also right now
where are you finding time to just sit
and listen to an audiobook you have to
kind of be multitasking running you made
me go on a five-mile walk yesterday I
was walking all over New York City you
would have thought I was Christopher
Columbus looking for new land
unbelievable what survey did you look I
actually did find anything
I had a pee the whole time too which was
super weird so I walked for five miles
and didn't pee as many of you will know
that's super uncomfortable that's fine
tell me your war stories in the in the
comments what's going on with
surveillance so
- nobody surprised a Chinese city is
proposing permanent health tracking with
a score based drinking and exercise with
a score based on drinking and exercise
habits and also sleeping so basically
this app would track how much you're
sleeping how much you're drinking on
which you're exercising but it would
tell the government nah I'm out I'm out
I'm not playing this game the tracking
system would work via digital barcode on
a person's phone the so called QR codes
become popular during the height of
China's growing virus outbreak they're
still being used to a lesser extent than
before but it's used to determine
whether a person could enter a building
or take public transport just think
about that for a second China's Chinese
city I don't even know how you pronounce
the city in the CNBC article is gonna
say now you can't ride the subway you're
fat well so it says no that's to say
you're fat you can't ride the subway
well some of the barcode apps work on a
traffic light system while red would
mean a person was a health risk in green
with mint they were able to enter so
what it originally started off was does
Polina have a temperature like her risk
level and then what they could do is
they could track a population and say
okay polina's are red she likely has
coronavirus or has tested positive she
went into contact with a bunch of people
who are green
therefore we should send push
notifications to the people who are
green telling them you've been in
contact with somebody who's positive for
coronavirus you should go and get tested
quarantine whatever again I disagree
with that that was the original purpose
now they're talking about again don't
let a crisis go to waste
oh we actually should just track how
much you drink and eat and exercise and
do all this other stuff hey how about we
tell the CCP to kick rocks right what
why would we ever allow them to do stuff
like this I have no clue but I'm just
not here for this game are you no so you
wouldn't want a health score no you'd be
read like I don't care I'm gonna die one
day if I died a couple years earlier
leave me alone I want to ride the subway
I don't care if I'm fat or not let me
just live my life I mean look what we
use we use Apple health right you know
and we look at the data we compare it
right you all yeah all that stuff but as
my information is for my usage how do
you know the government's aren't
actually using it
thank you well I'm trusting right and
again is entrusting the fact that Apple
has really good at cryptography and is
not sharing the data it all lives on the
phone like there's a bunch of things
they do around data privacy now could it
be hacked sure but there's a difference
between I have data and it gets hacked
and hey government here let me know if
you think that I'm skinny enough to ride
the subway like come on look at a health
data do you most track and keep I wish
that I wish that I had a timer on my
phone for how many hours a day plain
annoys me it would be very low she's
absolutely perfect I just wish to buy it
no I personally like the sleep metrics
that stuff's cool and then also I like
when it tells you if you worked out each
day keeps track and tells you like hey
you worked out for seven days the whole
month we do the little circles on the
Apple watch
alright what's going on with SpaceX the
SpaceX launch is tomorrow the first time
since people have been launched into
space since 2011 I believe - guys we're
going to the ISS SpaceX is the first
launch of NASA astronauts from the US is
2011 oh yeah the NASA shut down the
space like travel program basically and
they said we're not sending people to
space anybody and then Elon Musk the guy
everyone loves to hate everyone's [ __ ]
always complaining about all this
nonsense Elon Musk said as a private
citizen 20 years ago the company started
I think SpaceX started in like 2001 or
something it's almost 20 years ago he
said I'm going to get to Mars and he has
single-handedly he and his team have
brought back the space race it's awesome
so if you guys read the profile last
week there was a profile on Elon Musk
and also on Gwynne Shotwell she is
SpaceX a secret weapon she's asserted it
and what's your deal there's a video of
them both celebrating when the rocket
launch came back what's her deal yeah
she basically runs the company she
started as the seventh employee as an
engineer at SpaceX and work your way up
to president in
she is basically I think she's if not
one of the most important people at
SpaceX well she's definitely the second
most important person behind Elon Elon
is focused on engineering from what we
understand and Gwen is very focused on
basically all the operations the supply
chain the all that kind of stuff which
makes sense but it's gonna be super cool
highly suggest you guys watch tomorrow
Wednesday maybe we'll live stream it on
YouTube us yeah can i watch you into
space
hey I'm go do I gotta come back it's
just gonna be cool we said two people to
space they're going up and let's see
what happens
and look by the way this is super
dangerous I don't want to discount
I said don't count your chickens before
they hatch or eggs what is it
let's think with just normal language
without all those sayings because you
know you kind of twist it around in a
circle like a tornado it's very cool
it's dangerous but they gave they did
the final ready check today and it looks
like they're ready to go but there's
also a 40% chance it won't launch
because of bad weather you know the best
part the US has been paying Russia 80
million dollars a seat for almost a
decade to send our astronauts up oh
that's why they go there okay got it
yeah oh yeah we just pay Russia no
problem all that stuff you read in the
mainstream media about us not liking
Russia we just have 80 million dollars
every time we send a national night up
to space about time that we start giving
that to some American companies just
saying all right what's going on with
Elon Musk kid's name I mean yeah what is
this kid's name okay this is okay
there's speculation that they have to
change the name because in California
names can only use the 26 alphabetical
characters of the English language
according to the constitution of the
state so then on Sunday Grimes posted a
new photo and people are asking if they
changed the name because of Californian
laws and she said Roman numerals looks
better tbh to be on
so instead of 12 they just did X and
small I mean yeah we can't start naming
our kids r2d2 like come on you got to
have at least a letter or some fuse okay
so number but like that symbol is it
part of the yeah it is an A and an e
yeah not really
yeah it's fine it's close enough I mean
look it it is what it is like I actually
thought the funniest thing I saw on
Twitter was somebody said oh look Elon
Musk son got his first software update I
thought that was pretty good right but
like I mean it is what it is if they're
happy knock yourselves out if I need my
child that people rely say what but musk
is like oh yeah I make sense yeah it's
fine like again if they're happy who
cares everyone leave them alone if they
want to name our kid this whatever the
real question though is is somebody one
day gonna name their kid a mean or an
emoji could you just do an emoji see
what emoji would you name your kid if
you could the one with the chicken
hatching oh I would name him definitely
the laughing cry face yeah
just just every time every time someone
what's your name yeah or the for the
flame and they'd be I what's your name
that the fire god I was mad at my
parents when I was a little kid because
they didn't name me sir how literally
was like why do you just name me sir
Papa Leone oh then everyone had to say
sir all the time and my dad was like
shut up you're an idiot
and then when I brought my first brother
was born the one right underneath me
they asked me what his name should be
and I was too and I would put on a very
very hard-fought campaign to name him
shoe h OE i looked like i was adamant
about it for months that his name should
be shoe and my parents still tell the
story today they're like that's when we
knew that we were going to pay pay
special attention to you because you
want to name your brother shoe
I mean it's not a bad name yeah it's
fine I thought it was a good name at two
years wait guys also we had us like a
riddle last night before went to sleep
so if you know this I try to research it
leave it in the comments but so last
night I kept
asking questions and he was like
curiosity killed the cat and I was like
but why did the curiosity killed the cat
and so I googled and apparently there
was an article from like 1916 about this
woman's cat who would always lay in the
fireplace but like one day I got super
curious and went up to the chimney and
then I got stuck there and it died but
it was really tragic
this newspaper really lays it out do you
see how lame this looks
I put in some earphones and all of a
sudden I look lame that's why you got to
have air pods see look I just found
these in my pocket by the way that was
unplanned but like let me finish my cat
story so if you guys know but but it did
not originate in 1916 it originated way
before then so if anybody can find out
why the curious cat got killed and where
that thing comes from let me know why do
you have to know all the answers to
everything just say look curiosity
killed the cat who cares I need to know
look futuristic loser futuristic
lose-lose ristic just want you guys to
know all right that's it for lunch
Monday today we appreciate you watching
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get her lunch
money right we will see you tomorrow
let's face X livestream day it's gonna
be awesome
you look like a sheep see ya bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did don't
forget lunch money's now sponsored by
block five so go check them out there's
a link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina they've got 3 products
they can give you a US dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell crypto
currencies on their crypto exchange I
personally use the interest-bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risks associated but
8.6% it's pretty compelling so click on
the link in the description say thanks
to the folks that block by subscribe to
our channel like the video on
playing in the comment and we'll see you
guys tomorrow and be kind to your
friends